People always ask us
what advertising is.
It's a business of rejection.
You have to expect it.
Every damn day.
Every day.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I think advertising
is like vandalism.
It's loud, in your face, and
it's still there the next day.
If someone says,
this is going to be
really funny, don't do that.
Don't tell people how to feel.
Let them--
Yeah.
--feel through what you have.
Brands are allowed to
have a social conscience.
With Doritos, we did rainbow
chips for a gay pride parade.
And I think that's what's
changed in advertising.
You're allowed to bring
the social commentary
into the brand.
That's a big deal.
And we're going to talk
about a 30-second film.
Bud
Weise
[SCREAMS]
[WHOOSH]
[PHONE RINGS]
Hello?
MAN (ON PHONE): Hello.
For $10,000, who--
Aaron Burr.
Any commercial
starts with finding the truth--
Aaron Burr.
--within the problem.
We weren't motivated to
drink more milk by knowing
that it was good for us.
Your mom told you that.
Milk!
MAN (ON PHONE): I'm afraid
your time is almost up.
That was the whole
campaign, was making people
afraid to run out of milk.
Aaron Burr.
ANNOUNCER: Got milk?
JEFF GOODBY: A lot
of people think
that advertising is telling
somebody something that
isn't true, but getting
them to believe it.
That's not what we do.
RICH SILVERSTEIN: We understand
it's art serving capitalism.
But we want to be artists
in a business world.
Advertising is so fluid.
There is no
consistency that, this
is what you should be doing.
The key is to be fearless.
You're not going to
be right all the time.
Just put your heart into
something you feel good about.
JEFF GOODBY: You have
to have a little fire
burning inside yourself, and you
have to be open to the world.
Come and challenge us.
We want it.
Bring it.
Hi, I'm Goodby.
And I'm Silverstein.
And this is our MasterClass.
[MUSIC PLAYING]